lawmakers
uh reach a deal on one and a half
trillion dollar spending bill to avoid
shutdown and aid to ukraine okay
congressional leaders reached a
bipartisan deal ever early wednesday on
a one and a half trillion dollar
spending bill needed to avert a
government shutdown the legislation
includes 13.6 billion dollar aid to
ukraine folks that's kind of like us
getting a hundred thousand dollar loan
and i say i'm here to help you and i
give you
thirteen thousand dollars okay i said
hey uh not thirteen thousand dollars
thirteen hundred dollars so i get a
hundred thousand dollar loan because i'm
doing this for you because your family i
care about you guys so my ukraine we
really wanna help you here's a hundred
thousand dollars we get i give you
thirteen 1300 bucks ukraine like 13.6
billion eight to ukrainian european
allies and 15.6 billion of funding for
covet uh 19 vaccines testing treatments
in the united states and abroad
president biden had requested 10 billion
dollars for ukraine and european allies
and 22 and a half billion for covet
relief lawmakers face a friday deadline
to pass the spending measure and avoid a
weekend government shutdown let's print
some more money tom what do you think
about this i think it's horrible i just
did the math on this so basically
everybody listening average americans
13.6 billion to ukrainian and european
allies okay there's a war going on over
there it's very very important but every
man woman and nipple sucking child in
this country just gave 418 to ukraine
every one of them so when you start to
put it in that thing you say wow we did
yep and you take 1.5 trillion
that's basically what's at 4600.
this is crazy i mean this is
this is debt ceiling you know if my mom
had never said this to me hey kids
listen part of your inheritance you have
to inherit our credit card and deal with
it and pay it off
and to avert a family shutdown we're
increasing the credit limit by 10 grand
so that your dad and i can take an
anniversary trip to hawaii
so i would have been like wait a minute
can you get back to the part where i
inherit your credit card so if you were
to put it that way let's make a story a
little perspective make a storybook for
six years old
your parents said we're gonna increase
the debt ceiling for the family so your
dad and i can go to hawaii wonderful and
then when when we die remember you're
responsible for the credit card because
debt never dies liz what do you think
about this i think it's actually bigger
than that because i don't think that
there's an expectation
from the left at least that we are all
or our children are all actually going
to pay this you guys know what modern
monetary theory is
modern monetary theory is this very
radical leftist philosophy that you
don't have to worry about the debt or
the deficit that you can that a
government when the government is the
issuer of the currency
can and should just print as much money
as they need and that the deficit and
the debt are just a historical record of
how much has been printed and i think
modern monetary policy is something that
has actually been happening in our
country for
obviously not just this administration
not just not just liberal
administrations actually bush obama
trump now biden all of these all these
administrations have spent an exorbitant
amount of money but what happens is
under modern monetary policy not only is
that obviously going to lead to economic
ruling that's almost the secondary part
of it the point of modern monetary
policy is so that politicians at the
federal level in our legislature don't
have to ask themselves the questions how
do we fund our pet projects we have this
this ideological
smorgasbord in in a bill like this we
don't have to actually sit here and
debate in front of the american people
where do we get the money from this is
this worth spending your paycheck on all
they have to do is print the money so
this this modern monetary policy by the
way one of the propagators of modern
monetary policy one of the the lead
thinkers on this is named stephanie
kelton stephanie kelton is an advisor to
the biden administration and was an
advisor to both bernie sanders and joe
biden during their campaigns so this
modern monetary policy is is
acknowledged and embraced by the biden
administration they just hope that you
won't notice they hope you won't notice
because this is the way they push their
agenda through this is the way that it
can never be rolled back because our
legislators then don't actually have to
take into consideration whether they're
being wise whether people want their
money spent on a b or c policy whether
they want it spent on the green new deal
or whether they want it spent on
medicare for all or whether they want it
spent on ukraine they don't have to our
legislators never have to debate that
because people in a sense don't touch
that
they
yes we will we will have economic ruin
eventually but right now it's just their
way of pushing through their agenda and
so when i see when i see a bill like
that i immediately think well they're
going to print the money because that's
the way that they push their own agenda
unless we stop their ability to print
that money they're going to keep doing
things like this can you talk a little
bit more about her is she one of the
proponents of like great reset or
jubilee or inflate out infinity
she is she's played out of debt yeah so
she she's a professor a college
professor and she i mean she just speaks
probably more bluntly than anyone else
that i've heard about modern monetary
theory being completely dismissive of
the idea that you would ever have to pay
back you would ever have to pay back um
what you're spending or that she she
actually admits that taxation under
modern monetary theory isn't about
increasing revenue for government to pay
for whatever projects they have she
thinks that taxation is a form of
control that taxation is a way to ensure
that people don't ditch the us dollar um
because they see that this the spending
increases you know or devalues the
dollar it it increases inflation she
says taxation is just a way to make sure
that people stay using our currency
because you have to you have to earn the
us dollar in order to pay the us dollar
as taxes and to me that was the most
shocking admission sometimes if you
listen
no it doesn't work but this is what the
people in charge of our country are
doing right now if you dig into it i
find it to be incredibly fascinating but
also incredibly frightening but you know
whose name we're about to hear that we
haven't heard in about a month right joe
manchin
because
yeah obviously this you know every for
people not familiar how bills work right
uh or how laws get passed or how
stimulus you know bills end up getting
uh in the hands of the american people
this started in the house that does not
mean that it's going to pass the senate
and everything that we've saw with the
you know all the proposals that have
been put together in the house and then
boom the mansions of the world and the
cinemas of the world doesn't happen and
then you know all those side
conversations that really haven't
amounted to much so you know we get
caught up in the headlines that this is
what they're going to do this was going
to spend in by no means is this actually
happening so don't be surprised if you
hear joe manchin you know name the news
again and i hope so
circle the wagons with joe manchin well
first of all this mid mid year midterms
is going to be
i mean it's nothing is getting better
and better like you know you know what
is also scary they missed out on the op
this is going to sound crazy when i tell
you this they missed out on the
marketing opportunity of saying covet is
done
so the way they did it even as a
marketing strategist you didn't do it
the right way the the ukraine
issue debacle that's taking place over
there they they were not able to
capitalize off the marketing opportunity
for biden
fauci and all of them to come out and
say folks
great news
after extensive strategies with our
covet relief team and you know vaccines
and all this other stuff
everything's going back to normal we are
leaving the mask and we're leaving this
a move like that if they would have done
that two months ago or even six weeks
ago
that would have helped them for midterms
it's almost as if their marketing
strategy is not even a smart marketing
strategist because everything right now
is what so let's just say midterms come
up what are people voting for
gas prices what else am i voting for
inflation what else am i voting for a
war what else am i
what like what do you what victory do
you have they have no victory right
they're going to pay price for it
from a marketing standpoint
they just tried the disappearing act
with anthony fauci all of a sudden did
you notice he was just gone from the
airway yeah he's such that's actually a
really good point when's the last time
you saw vouchers that's not a good
marketing strategy they should have
capitalized off of it i was surprised
biden didn't um basically declare that
kovid was over during his state of the
union i thought he was especially
because in new york the governor said
listen we're going to take mass mandates
out of school kids aren't going to have
to wear that anymore she announced that
on monday but instead of saying it's
going to go into effect tomorrow she
said wednesday and i thought oh well
biden's going to be the one to announce
that in the state of the union no he
didn't he didn't touch on it maybe
because i mean the american people have
have seen the light in a certain sense
that i mean they're yes you're going to
see people wearing masks voluntarily for
years to come a certain a certain
percentage of people but fauci fauci has
dipped out of the spotlight as the
spotlight has turned to those biological
labs in ukraine because that's the part
regardless of whether you feel the fear
about the virus people don't like
corruption and politicians and they
don't like that fouchy through the nih
funded the wuhan institute of virology
which perhaps perhaps this virus was
tinkered with in in that lab they do not
like that and this looks like it could
be happening again in ukraine with the
biological uh weapons labs that the u.s
is kind of trying to defend against
right now but can't tyler is this
something you're excited about you want
to give a shout out to our friends at
the
babylon we love these guys so attention
starved dr fauci agrees to box jake paul
what a picture right now oh that's
horrifying those guys do a phenomenal
job both guys do fantastic this is just
anecdotal weight 95.
you know what i got in the mail was that
last week what my government issued
covet testing kit came in the mail last
week like we're done with covid right
everybody kind of agrees it's just off
the radar and sure enough when i when
nobody needs it right we all get our
government did you order it or did it
just get sent to you just got sent to me
interesting this just showed up in the
mail i was like oh i got a package i
wonder where it came from and outcomes
you know i'm offended i haven't gotten
one yet it really hurts my feelings so
if you enjoyed this little segment from
the podcast click over here to watch the
entire podcast and if you've not
subscribed to the channel please do so
take care everybody
[Music]